- [Quizzer] Nine times 18.
(beep) (laughter)
- Oh!
162.
(bell dings)
(upbeat music)
Really.
Getting the nerves out.
Getting them nerves out.
- If I can't do basic math,
I'm gonna be a little
disappointed in myself.
- I feel very confident.
I did really well in
math back in high school,
so should be pretty good.
(upbeat music)
- [Quizzer] Times eight.
- Oh.
- 64?
(bell dings)
- [Quizzer] Nine times 18.
- No, I don't got it.
(laughs)
- Oops.
- Yeah, just call on him.
I think he's got it.
- 162?
(bell dings)
(laughter)
- [Quizzer] 500 divided by four.
- Like I could do that in my head.
I can't.
125, I got it.
(bell dings)
Woo.
- [Quizzer] 15 times 15.
- I think it's, um--
- Ew, ew, ew.
225?
- Is it?
(bell dings)
Damn.
(applause)
I can do it,
I just need a little time,
you know what I mean?
He's just quick.
(Paper taps)
(light music)
- [Quizzer] 20 times 95.
- Thousand...
1,900?
(bell dings)
Yes.
Score. (laughs)
- [Quizzer] Nine times seven.
- 64.
(buzzer sounds)
- 63.
(bell dings)
- Snaps.
- [Quizzer] 500 divided by four.
- 125.
(bell dings)
(applause)
(laughs) I thought I was
gonna lose for a minute there.
I think I did my adults proud.
- Unexpected.
(upbeat music)
- [Quizzer] 12 times three.
- Oh!
36.
(bell dings)
- [Quizzer] 156 times four.
- 624.
(laughter)
(bell dings)
- [Quizzer] 15 times 15.
225?
(bell dings)
(applause)
I feel a little bit ashamed,
but I'm proud of the kids.
They're the future of this country.
- [Quizzer] Awe.
12 times three.
- 36.
(bell dings)
- [Quizzer] Seven times nine.
- Oh seven times nine?
Oh, dang it.
- (laughs) 63.
(bell dings)
- [Quizzer] Nine times 18.
- 162.
(bell dings)
(applause)
- I still feel good
'cause they're grownups,
and I'm just a kid.
Well I'm very glad I beat everyone
because I gave it my very best.
- I think it's just that he's got
like these quick arms
that go up really fast.
I think that's, it's really not the math,
it's more like his quick arm.
♪ On the phone ♪
♪ 'Cause you too small ♪
♪ Nose hangin' out ♪
♪ Neck's too long ♪
♪ He's missed and right. ♪
(sign squeaks)